whatever they spoil like say it was
wrong Stark's death we should do exactly
what happened to Rome to them for the
heads off of our heads I say Joffrey
take punishments I think they should be
put in a pit of unsullied and the pit
close in on them and what happens and
now I couldn't possibly tell you
unsullied secret because the people who
spoil are the worst people in the world
perhaps they should be jailed yes
everyone who seems very lucky or yeah
killed me I don't want to go to medieval
on them but um I don't know maybe kind
of like I don't know how can we make
someone shut up or even type it's kind
of like typing as well isn't it yeah
fingers yeah yeah well you and Hans I
don't think of ya as you and then you'll
find I just think that they should be
banned from the internet this is there's
an immense sense of kind of ownership
about the shows that the people of read
the books and the people who've got into
this and I think of a sort of real
respect for for the storytelling on the
complexity of it is a tricky one isn't
it because we've got people like you are
some really tricky questions and we
can't answer them and we've been told no
don't answer the questions and then you
get sort of Tourette's when you're in a
situation like this and you say the
wrong thing that you have to show us
certain amount of restraint which I to
show a certain amount mister I didn't
read ahead in the books for ages because
I wanted to explore the world the game
of thrones' Sam explored it would be
surprised along with Sam so I think I
think it has to be a decision that you
make really